in a live-performance situation I mean  you want to take into the size of  audience you're performing for is it an  intimate setting in maybe a nightclub or  something you know like this setup maybe  I have a cello player and a pianist and  a soft drum thing and we're just doing  this sort of mellow jazzy thing or or  even stripped-down versions of my my  songs you have to be able to command a  presence that invites people in and I  don't mean again going back to this is  me and I'm gonna get your attention like  sometimes the more quiet stance and more  contemplative you are you take a second  and you silence and then you speak and  you set up a song is so engaging